this is a scary weapon
your edge is razor sharp
this weapon sir will
the war galac
originating in the philippines during
the 16th century the war galock featured
a straight double-edged blade with no
tip due to the spanish occupation at the
time filipinos were outlawed from having
pointed swords and the blade was often
used for vegetation and chopping wood
however by the philippine revolution in
1896 filipinos adapted to the tipless
weapon and it became a weapon of war it
was so effective in battle and inspired
later variations of the weapons such as
the british military's army galac in the
early 1950s
bladesmiths to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do we'll take
your sword and deliver hacks and slashes
on this big carcass
brian you're up first you ready for this
absolutely
i really like how the blade turned out
but i'm super nervous depending on where
you hit that blade you know it can
always snap apart
bladesmiths but unfortunately i'm still
recovering from an injury so anthony one
of my senior instructors of mark ida
kali will be the butcher to your pork
chop
[Music]
all right brian let's talk about your
blade first up your edge is razor sharp
it lacerated easily through bones to the
spine
the one issue here is that you have a
very blocky handle aside from that it
will kill good job thanks
matt ready to chop i've been ready let's
do this
i'm really nervous
but as long as this blade doesn't wrap
around in a circle and hug this pig i'm
in good shape
[Music]
okay matt it's balancing weight is very
forward for a chopper but your edge is
sharp enough to lacerate into the
carcass it did chop the spine it did
chop bone
this
will kill
thank you
gentlemen
this is a strength test to test the
strength and durability of your edge i'm
going to chop into these huge logs 10
times remember this test is all about
what happens to your weapons and not
what happens to the logs brian you're up
first you ready i think so yeah
all right
[Music]
[Music]
made it
well brian your edge held up perfectly
there's no bending no warping just still
razor sharp all the way down man
it was fun to swing well done thank you
matt you're up you ready give it a try
all right
[Music]
[Music]
ah
well matt there's so much forward weight
that it actually
bent that way
on the plus side
your edge held beautifully i mean
there's no problems with that edge at
all it's still very sharp
but this s-bend in it it's significant
[Music]
blade smith's you both brought in some
pretty extraordinary historic weapons
but in this arena of competition there
can only be one forged and fired
champion
brian
congratulations you are the new forged
and fire champion
thank you matt unfortunately your blade
did not make the cut please surrender
your glock
even with losing at the end of the day i
don't feel like i really lost because i
went way further than i ever expected
i don't know enough about it yet that i
can make that perfect blade so you know
i'll keep learning
brian you are the new forged and fire
champion and that comes with a check for
ten thousand dollars good job thank you
guys thank you
please present your weapon to the judges
it feels great to be forged in fire
champ
can't believe i won it's awesome
i would say if somebody wants to start
learning how to make a knife start out
watching fortune fire just start at
episode one binge watch
[Music]
the morrow chris
the chris came into existence around
1361 a.d in the kingdom of majapahit
east java
believed to be the primary weapons
wielded by asian warriors its
distinctive wavy blade creates a wider
wound during combat causing the victim
to quickly bleed to death
the hilt is viewed as a work of art and
is often carved in meticulous detail
from precious wood gold or ivory in
popular culture the chris can be seen in
the video game mortal kombat
the unique design for morro chris has
been made more distinct by its fluid
wave-like edges it can thrust but its
primary purpose is slashing and chopping
to test your chris's ability to perform
according to its ancient design i will
use it to chop and slice against these
moving targets
mace you're up first are you ready sure
nice
nice balance nice recovery allows you to
just move with a blade
good job thank you
mary you're next you ready certainly am
[Music]
well murray
the balance of this blade allows me to
chase an attack and will come with me on
the recovery to go to another attack it
will stay with me it doesn't go away
from me
it will slice
good job thank you the quality of the
cut is obvious to the human eye my blade
was the sharper and more cleanly cutting
blade
to test the lethality of your chris i
will take your weapon i'm going to
strike into this animal carcass mace
you're up first you ready yes sir
[Music]
well it cut cleanly through the spine
all the way through the meat in one big
sweeping slash
it will kill
good job thank you very much
where are you up next you ready yep
[Music]
when cutting through there was a slight
drag in the feel of the cut but it did
cut very cleanly through it's a very
very sharp blade
it will kill
doug's not giving me positive feedback
about the way it cut
but i know that often it can just be the
angle
of the blade edge in relationship to the
motion of the arm
[Music]
bamboo is a very durable material ounce
for ounce it is stronger than concrete
brick or wood to test the strength of
your chris i will deliver four strikes
into the bamboo to see how well your
weapon stands up mace here up
i'm confident in my construction methods
but there's always that fear that your
blade will come apart
i'm a bit nervous
welp
no damage to the blade sir
it chopped nicely but a couple of times
over there it didn't want to fall out of
my hand just because it's so heavy on
the blade but nonetheless looks like
your edge did hold up
excellent mary you're up next you ready
yes i am
[Applause]
okay murray looks like your blade edge
held up with the chops it almost clearly
sliced all the way through
but there is now an issue that we're
looking at with your blade i think there
might be a little bend here caused from
chopping into the bamboo
but other than that
it still has a very sharp edge the
strength of the blade held up
good job thank
you gentlemen you have both done
immaculate work but there can only be
one champion
mace
you are the forged empire champion
yes congratulations
thank you maurice job man thanks very
much happy for you murray
unfortunately your chris did not make
the cut
murray i find that weapon absolutely
beautiful and comfortable but
the fact that there's a soft core in
there somewhere and that it picked up a
bend where your opponent's blade did not
that was the deciding factor and that's
why we had to let you go
murray
please surrender your weapon
while there's always a disappointment
when one puts their best effort forward
and doesn't win thank you gently yeah
thank you for it i do feel an
overwhelming sense of gratitude for
having been able to participate
mace made the better blade
and i'm proud of him
mace congratulations woo
nice
fantastic i mean the steel's beautiful i
like how you did the file work on the
blade the blade held up beautifully the
edge is razor sharp should be
exceptionally proud of that piece here
great job
i'm the fortune fire champion i feel
good
and i'm glad it came out on top i'm the
tiger
is a two-handed sword carried into
battle by the diax a group of tribes
that have lived on the island of borneo
for thousands of years though most dayak
weapons doubled his useful tools the
panda was only used in war forced from
iron the panda features an angled blade
and could be swung downwards with two
hands an iron cross piece was inserted
through a hole at the end of the handle
protecting the user's hand the blade was
sometimes decorated with hair or rattan
plant until the early 20th century dayak
raiders plundered coastal settlements
for resources money and even enemy heads
proving just how deadly this weapon
could be bladesmiths this is the
sharpness test
to see how sharp your weapons are i will
attempt to cut through these web of
ropes with three identical strikes if
they're sharp i should meet no
resistance
joey up first you ready let's do it
it's all inspiring to see what these
guys have come up with with this
challenge seeing these ropes crisscross
and everything i'm a little apprehensive
about it because i didn't get to test it
on a rope but it's something to cut this
blade is gonna cut
[Music]
well joe
all the weight is at the tip of the
blade so when i come down it wants to
draw me forward and the recovery is a
little bit harder on the way back
you have a sharp edge over here that i
almost meant
no resistance overall sir your blade
will cut
pete you're up next you ready
yes sir let's do this
okay pete it is a sharp blade the
balance
is light you have a lighter blade here
it's not as heavy to pull forward it's a
good job the only issue i have
is that i kind of ran out of handle here
i would have liked to see a little
pummel here or probably even a longer
handle so it's easier to control and not
feel like i'm at the end of my rope so
to say
overall this weapon sir will cut
thank you
all right bladesmiths next up is a kill
test
now the pandat was a weapon used by
headhunting tribes in borneo to see how
lethal your weapon is i will take your
pandat and i will deliver one blow
to this carcass
let's see how much damage your weapon
can do joe you're up first you ready
let's bring it let's do it
[Music]
okay joe the balance feels so forward
heavy that when you slice through this
carcass it pulled me into it and cut
cleanly all the way through
this weapon sir will kill good job thank
you
peter up next you ready yes i am
[Music]
[Music]
okay pete the difference with your blade
is that it's light and because it's
light i can use velocity to help cut
through this carcass
this weapon sir will kill
good job
thank you
all right gentlemen this is the strength
test to test the strength and durability
of your blades we're going to hook them
into our machine here which is going to
chop into this bundle of sugar cane
now if your blades are tempered properly
they should cut into the cane without a
problem
if not we might get them to bend warp
but we'll see what happens joe you're
already rigged up on the machine you
ready to go let's go all right let's do
this
all right joe
three
two one
all right so joe now when i pull this
out of the machine
there's a bit of a bend right here in
the ricasso kind of a gap
right along the edge of the blade in the
guard had that warp point it got here it
had that warp when it got here it's
actually offset it's got a little bit of
a twist maybe a five degree twist i
couldn't get it out whenever i built it
well it may have gotten bigger during
that test
overall
the edge held up fine no damage
whatsoever
it's got a good shape good job
thanks sir all right pete you're all
locked in ready for this
i am all right
all right pete
three
two
one
[Music]
all right pete and you could actually
see how much this blade
flexed when it went into the into the
cane
and came back to true which is always
what i want to see definitely sharp well
put together
feels good all right well done p
thank you
pete
joe this is one of the tightest
competitions that we've had it was a
difficult decision but that final
decision has been made
the forged and fire champion is
pete congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion
joe
your pen dot did not make the cut doug
will explain
joe the presentation of both blades
performed equally well
so much so that we have to go to the
finer details of its performance the
angle of your pandat being so top heavy
was harder to control in all the tests
that we were doing
and for that we have to let you go
joe
please surrender your weapon
this experience has taught me like many
things in life to try
dare to fail if you fail so what
feeling kind of disappointed right now
but
at least i tried
pete congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion and we'll be receiving
that check for 10 grand good job thank
you
[Applause]
how you feeling right now pete
feel pretty good
i'm feeling like i could just roll on
the floor and bust out laughing it feels
real good feels real good to win
i'm going home
the forging fire champion
and i know all 24 of my grandkids are
going to be excited for grandpa
[Music]
the copy line
according to legend the campilon was the
sword that killed explorer ferdinand
magellan at the battle of maktan in what
is now the philippines
the heavy spur tip sword was used by
island warriors in battle and could chop
off two heads in one swing
the single-edged blade could also cut
through its scabbard with no resistance
allowing it to be quickly wielded
without being unsheathed
the campylon's distinctively carved
wooden hilt was sometimes embellished
with strands of hair
offering a unique and appealing
appearance for this otherwise deadly
weapon
all right gentlemen to test the
sharpness of your blades i'll be
chopping through our cat's cradle of
rope here now todd you're up first you
ready
i am
i'm proud of how my compilon turned out
you tried to do everything right
you don't know if it's going to work out
that way
lord help me
[Music]
all right todd
this blade
has all the weight right here you know
it's a weapon that's designed to be used
one or two-handed but controlling all
that forward weight definitely puts this
as a two-hand only sword
it's a good-looking piece and it
definitely is a cutter
michael you're up you're ready let's do
it
i am
a little worried
if dave thinks that todd's sword's heavy
he's gonna really dislike mine
[Music]
still a very heavy weapon
i would have zero confidence swinging
this one-handed it wouldn't get away
from me
but the weight distribution on your
blade is further back which gave me
quite a bit more control to chop those
ropes
it's definitely a cutter so
good job nicely done thank you
bleedsmiths this is the kill test i'm
going to take your campilon and deliver
lethal blows on this big carcass todd
you're up first you ready i sure am
let's do this
my concern on the pig test is my blade
is thicker in the middle i'm
hoping mine will go all the way through
it won't slow it down by the thickness
[Music]
[Music]
all right todd the swing over here
almost cut all the way and of course
with an easy swing on the way back
it cut the pig in half
the campilon
will kill
thank you
all right michael your turn you ready
let's do it let's do this
i'm excited
i want to see my sword cut through a pig
all right
so even though it is a heavier blade
its counterbalance allows to wield going
forward
and backward easily so it was an easy
recovery for the final chop
overall your compelent will kill
thank you good job
all right gentlemen to test the strength
and durability of your blade i'll be
chopping into this green bamboo
the strength test is always the toughest
on a blade i didn't want to get it too
hard
i'm nervous because this test proves you
did it right if you didn't there's a
flaw in it it's going to reveal itself
here
whoa
yeah i don't feel any damage whatsoever
on the edge
it did a job on that bamboo and it's
clean
well done
thank you michael you ready let's do it
okay i am still recovering from the
trauma of watching dave use todd's sword
on that bamboo
this test i believe is the one that's
gonna make or break my blade
well
i thought i saw something but it was
just bamboo stuck to your blade
it's fine there's no damage there
your blade hasn't changed shape at all
good job well done
going in like this and we're so close
now it's up to the judges it's their
pick
and so i'm a little nervous
all right blade smiths from the moment
you guys lit those cold forges until
this moment you've put in a lot of hard
work it's been a lot of stress
but in this arena of competition there
can only be one forged and fired
champion and that champion is
michael congratulations you are the
forged and fire champion
todd unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut todd this is what we judges
expect in the third round two beautiful
blades equally matched but it comes down
to the finer details
your blade isn't as well balanced as
that of your opponents and your design
and detail were not as strong
so for those reasons
you have to let you go
understand
be proud of your work todd because it
was a close call
but please surrender your weapon
i never thought about making it this far
this is the first sword i've ever made
i'm proud of what i did and it held up
good
i didn't think that i would be capable
of doing this
and you never know what kind of strength
you can find
michael congratulations you are the
forged fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
brother
all right what's going on inside of
there is surreal uh
wasn't expected starting this
competition but huge affirmation of my
skills please present your weapon to the
judges
it's surreal it hasn't really set in yet
all the years that i've put into this
hobby this craft and now to be here and
be the fortune fire champion it's pretty
amazing
the killer wing
one of malaysia's deadliest traditional
weapons to kellowing is a single-edged
sword used in tribal warfare in the 18th
century this light short sword with its
curved belly and clip tip was a brutal
slasher and stabber
during its brief rule of malaysia the
dutch colonial government deemed the
sword so lethal they banned it from use
before developing their own version to
quell uprisings
with ornate features like an elaborately
carved hilt for an intricate hook on the
spine the kelawang became an elegant
accessory worn at formal events today
its dutch counterpart is still worn at
ceremonies by the royal netherlands army
bladesmiths to see what kind of lethal
damage your keller one will do i will
take your kelawang and deliver slashes
and thrust on these ballistics dummies
hunter you're up first you ready whereas
i'm gonna get my blade is very sharp um
i cut through probably half a case of
water bottles took no edge deformation
and it's sharp so i just gotta hope it's
good enough for the dummies while my arm
is healed enough to wield a knife on the
ratchet strap slash my arm is still
healing so bladesmiths please welcome rj
marcaida
he will have the pleasure of wielding
your weapon
[Music]
[Music]
all right now just talk about your
calendar right here
your edge over here is sharp it glides
through and lacerates your weapon when
slashing broke some ribs your kelly
wangser
will kill thank you all right tim you
ready
as i'll ever be
100 got really good feedback that first
slice went in deep so he's got one
mother of an edge on that thing
i hope mine does that well
[Music]
[Music]
all right tim the first thing i noticed
about is your handle the minute you grab
on to it it's all void enough to let us
know and index where the edge is
you have a tip that's also very sharp
and pointed that when it penetrated not
only penetrate it broke some ribs also
your kelly one
will kill
thank you
next up the strength test bladesmiths
we've taken these parts from a buffalo
plow and to test the strength and
durability of your kellowangs i am going
to chop into them
remember this test is all about what
they do to your callawang and not what
your colorways do to them hunter you're
up first you ready where's i'm gonna get
i'm really nervous my sword's lean is
pretty narrow this seems like it's gonna
be a lot more brutal on the blades than
what i was expecting
[Music]
well hunter your blade broke the main
issue
was that at the intersection of the
blade and this
decorative curl
there was a saw cut that came in
it's a sharp notch and we call those
stress risers they're a place where
something is going to break the way you
protect against that problem as you
round the bottom of that notch and it
tends to dissipate the energy better
hunter your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure and can no longer
continue with testing
however you're not out of this
competition yet tim your blade also must
survive at least five whacks in order
for you to move forward after seeing
hunter's blade snap
i'm worried mine might snap off as well
[Music]
well tim it held up can't see any
evidence of of the activity on the edge
of this blade it's still razor sharp
i really enjoyed swinging it nice job
thank you so much
hunter your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure for that reason i
have to dismiss you from the forge
i'm feeling pretty disappointed i don't
know i just thought it was going to be
more solid than that if i could start
over again i'd make the blade a little
wider a little thicker and make sure i
didn't have a stress point in it
i still want to go full time
i've definitely learned a lot
everybody to make from l1 is going to be
better
well tim all your hard work paid off you
turned in a keller wing that's deadly
and let's face it looks like a 10 000
weapon worthy of the title forged in
fire champion congratulations
[Applause]
i wanted to prove to myself more than
anything that i am at this level
it feels really great to be fortunate
fire champion i can let a lot of those
doubts slip to the side move past them
bladesmithing it's not just what i do it
is who i am
the javanese chris
a symbol of status in the javanese
warrior that chris has been one of the
most prized possessions of indonesian
culture since the 14th century
the weapon includes an ornate pistol
grip hilt and a long narrow double-edged
blade that could either be straight or
wavy
much like the ending guitar the crisp
was used for thrusting or jabbing and it
was not uncommon for warriors to wield
one in each hand to take down an
opponent
intensely personal possessions chris's
are often at the center of job and
rituals particularly during marriages
and are passed down as heirlooms
all right blade smiths this is the kill
test to find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do i will take
your crisis and deliver slashes and
thrust on this big carcass john you're
up first you ready for this oh yeah
let's do this
i'm just so nervous at this point that
my legs are actually shaking and i don't
know if i'm just so nervous to see it in
the hands of somebody else or nervous
it's gonna break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good job
i think having these waves here
pretty much answers what kind of damage
that will do every thrust pierces in i
could feel it riding the skin and
cutting if you look at the wound channel
on the way out it's that wide this
definitely has a sharp edge overall sir
it will kill
thank you all right steve it's your turn
you ready yep let's do this
[Music]
dude that's impressive
all right steve's talk about your chris
here
the balance of this blade is really good
it's done in such a way to where i can
really get speed in cutting and because
your angles of the edge over here it's
almost like an acute edge it allows to
cut deeply into this big carcass it's
light it's fast and it's sharp and it
will kill
thank you very much
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
to test the strength and durability as
well as the overall construction of your
javanese crisp i'm going to be stabbing
them in and out of these oil drums
remember this test is all about what
these drums do to your swords and not
what your swords do to these drums john
you're up first you ready let's do it
all right
[Music]
[Music]
first things first john everything held
up really well the one thing that gives
me a pause is the tip took some dulling
all in all really well done
thank you
steve you're up next you ready yep all
right
[Music]
[Music]
well steve
i love the shape and the design of your
chris it's very classic i don't see any
damage even though it's stabbed quite
deeply into the drum is still razor
sharp well done thank you
[Music]
all right gentlemen you survived our
kill test on a brutal strength test now
it's time to find out if your blades
still have an edge it's time for the
sharpness test
i'll be attacking these bags with stabs
and slashes and unlike the strength test
this is all about what your blades do to
those targets john you're up first
you're ready i'm ready okay
with my
edge i feel like steve's blade performed
slightly better in the tests i'm hoping
that something's going to happen to bump
me up so i can be ahead in the
competition
[Music]
[Music]
cool
cut all right john that's really a
beautiful looking blade
as far as the cuts went it cut very
cleanly there's no jagged cutting on
those bags which is really nice your
handle i like the shape here it's a
little bit short for me
i'm kind of bumping right against here
but nicely done thank you
steve you're up you ready yep
right now i think it's neck and neck i
am pretty nervous my legs are locked up
if this doesn't cut as good as john's i
won't win
[Music]
way to go buddy
all right steve design design-wise your
blade i really like it your handle i
like that
i know that's not going anywhere it's
easy to index as far as the cuts go
i think they speak for themselves
they're all clean straight through
really good job steve thank you very
much appreciate it
john steve the judges have made their
final decision there are no losers here
today gentlemen both of you have made
excellent weapons the next forest and
fire champion is
[Music]
steve congratulations you're the new
forest and fire champion
john you brought us a beautiful and
exceptional weapon no one can take that
away from you but it would just
outperform during our test for that
reason we're studying home
thank you
unfortunately at this time i have to ask
you to please surrender your blade
you know nobody likes to lose but just
being here was a win for me thank you
guys i grew a ton both as a knife maker
but as a person as well
first thing i'm going to do when i get
home is hug my little girl and wife i
think they're going to be proud of me
for sure
[Music]
steve congratulations you are the new
forged and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with the check for ten
thousand dollars good job great thank
you
i won yeah
i don't know what to say i'm glad it
happened you know the cutting just tells
the story john did really good job i
think my blade just cut a little better
than his my name's steve coster and i am
the winner of forge and fire
the panavis
known as a chopping tool for both
agriculture and combat the panavas
earned its place as a weapon of war in
the southern philippines during the 19th
century its sharp forward curved blade
acted like an oversized meat cleaver and
delivered deep clean cuts which made it
ideal for executions
on the battlefield warriors carrying a
pinavas would follow behind the front
lines and behead anyone unlucky enough
to have survived the first wave of
attacks
this is the kill test to see what kind
of lethal damage your padavas will do i
will take your weapon and deliver
slashes across this big carcass
josh you're up first you ready
absolutely let's do this
[Music]
yes
okay josh
this is a scary weapon it's got a sweet
spot in there that allows for a nice
chop and of course
second chop cut through the spine
the ribs
everything your panabas
will kill
good
job good job all right ray it's your
turn you ready you betcha let's do this
i'm thinking i just got to do as good as
josh did
but i loved it when doug said it will
keel
that's with two e's
[Music]
i need me a cup of coffee ray you bet
in the feel of this i can feel the blade
already wanting to chomp the arc is
right where the sweet spot is
that allows the blade to cut cleanly all
the way through and overall cupanabas
will kill my favorite next stop is
strength test dave
gentlemen in 1521 the explorer magellan
landed on the island of cebu sparking
several decades of conflict between the
philippines and spain so to test your
panamas i'm going to strike a spanish
mauryan twice with the edge of your
weapon now this is not about what your
weapon does to the helmet but what the
helmet does to your weapon
josh you're up you ready
sure okay
[Music]
[Music]
i don't see any wrinkling any
deformation any rolling on your edge
which is pretty amazing i'll put some
dents in that helmet
ray
you ready for this can't hardly wait
let's make it happen
[Music]
okay ray i can see a little shiny spot
here
it's just that wire edge feels like it's
kind of tip just a hair
it's definitely still sharp
very nice it felt good in the hand thank
you next up is the sharpness test for
that i'll give you back to doug
bladesmiths we know your blades can kill
you know your blades are strong but are
they still sharp to test the edge
retention of your blade i will take your
pandavas and i will cut the rope that
will release the sandbag which simulates
an oncoming attack i will then run the
blade across this and cut it
josh you're up first you ready yes sir
[Applause]
yes
oh he died
me liking the feel
feels good in the hand enough to move
and maneuver in close quarter combat
and overall
your weapon will cut that's all i ever
wanted to hear
ray it's your turn you ready you betcha
let's do this let's do it
[Music]
this is going to be tough ray i know
what i like your blade too
your banabas definitely is a cutter and
it's easy to wheel your panavas
will cut thank you sir good job
heading into judging i feel really neck
and neck with ray but i can see myself
like the end of a john hughes film
with that panama's blade above my head
it's gotta happen
josh ray there can only be one forged
and fire champion in this arena and that
champion is
josh
ray unfortunately your pinabas did not
make the cut jason knight will explain
when it comes down to this type of
competition sometimes just the little
details are the game changer ray josh
had a little bit more subtleties in his
design his handle was octagonally fasted
and he had file work in the spine and
those subtle details are the reason why
josh's blade won
ray
please surrender your weapon
buddy you got it give me a hug
well i feel great
i came here not to prove
anything i just enjoy
the competition
my knife performed and has not performed
so he got the money and i got the funds
josh congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and will be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars
you're super excited right now aren't
you this is like
it just
feels so good all of you fans wherever
the hell you came from
i love you guys josephine with their
designs that helped me get through round
two with the handle thank you
you made daddy win
i am the forced and fire champion
that's what the heaven
[Applause]
sorry
[Music]
you